was it annoying to work with chris evans
who always seemed so prepared for
everything
he's right there
it was scary to me my childhood toys
were most little action figures and
they've all been done he-man and g.i joe
thunder cats ninja turtles
have they done a thundercats movie why
not not that i thought yeah why not
alright so this is my last question um
if you could film a childhood toy of
yours what would it be and why this is
where they're both of you if i could
film
um do a whole ass film
a whole lifestyle
i'll be honest chris you haven't heard
this but like that my agent said they
sent a little thing and they said
and my eyes just scanned through the
thing and it was like buzz lightyear and
i was like yes and then i saw your name
and i just and i didn't read the rest of
the email i just went yes